hello and welcome to this video playing
GM Hayek no no name but it's a just has
gotten his all-time high with 262 650
okay from the Ukraine see what's line it
goes for ya and I really can decide if I
should play the bishop g5g five first or
III both is very very valid yeah this is
one of the main lines and usually play
it with this age for bat em and never
completely sure this is right there's
this takes takes a for stuff yeah what
is where where it gets very messy
usually and I feel like this isn't the
best possible way of playing okay h5 he
wants to do what 95 I guess yeah I still
think this is correct
certainly not g5 so this one um I was
thinking just f3 here actually but maybe
he will go at five this is not
completely out of the out of the picture
a very very crude thing would be to just
take the pawn and one that sometimes you
can just take it okay I'm trying this
you know usually quite skeptical towards
that idea I'm just not sure how about
this particular position because he's
got that quite unusual um configuration
on the Kings side maybe just be six but
amazingly tough position this is kind of
thing yeah i can take c 5 which is what
i have to do probably yeah now i can
take one before i can take the seven as
well
taking you force the probably the normal
choice oh no maybe Bishop c6 I should
have taken with the other one I think
maybe the ship c6 is always awkward yep
that's very awkward I have a stupid
mistake hmm now that was a bad idea very
bad idea should have taken with the
other one
wow there's absolutely no margin for
error in this position I'm just lost no
it's not nothing more nothing less I
think you know I think at least maybe
I'm wrong with I think I'm more or less
losing okay f3 goes b6 and then I can
take one GF I ok ok ok ok this I'm not
losing but if this is not what I wanted
I didn't see industry that after b6 I
have 90 x g5 which is at least playable
even though I mean yes fantastic
compensation for the porn so hmm that's
so bad
got this pressure them anyway
okay um 54 maybe and I Scott Bishop f2
but is it is it that bad can also go
rogue f1 here ok so time morning
hmm I would like to get some kind of
intuitive probably not suited not easy
not easy anymore
yeah check this is not fun we rooting 2d
59 f6 is a little idea but I can a kid
named Andy can even take because his
chick no it's not checkmating me as I
can do that we should be one takes takes
takes check with 8 seconds this is the
problem the position is okay i think but
i have no time
maybe went on time basically no matter
what he does now it was just a very
awkward position to play check wait for
it yeah okay there was not about chess
in the end just wanted to win win win on
time the problem was I couldn't this was
not a position that I could play quickly
it was just just far too awkward I
actually did not really approves I
didn't want to do that I didn't see that
I didn't appreciate she takes d5
correctly so I shouldn't probably take
one c5 yeah very complicated position
very complicated Quincy too maybe I
should leave the comp wants to take on
g6 play Quincy to the move h5 is very
debatable here it's not you don't have
to play it let's say avid it it's kind
of in the spirit of this position so
yeah this is what the engine wants to do
talk to very tough to assess and it
wants to play this move and now we'll
just play castles why can a lot cover it
that's what I wonder okay night b3 as a
strong move ok so this is what the
computer wants to play gives why the
minimum advantage fits well it's just
super complicated yeah this is this is
not a good idea I didn't evaluate this
this correctly yeah and now I should I
should have understood this a bit better
that I can actually take and player 3
this position he definitely has
compensation may be more than enough but
the main problem is that it is
absolutely awful to play with white
because you're defending the whole time
and I didn't even do a bad job yeah i
think the janitor is always on equal
something like this so i actually did
play it play it well i was just too slow
about it yeah around here yes has
already overstretched is his play Queen
f6a Rugare six is good scoot for white
now for example but ok I was happy to
get something that I could play rather
quickly but it wasn't too late the idea
of course it's a draw if it just takes
but he wanted to have to make some moves
to to win on time I'd rather let me
remote iam mmm gel tough very tough game
this position if I don't take on on a 4
and 0 and a force is very unclear ok
thanks for watching